[Music]
look what I become
oh man okay so we got a special podcast
today let me lower the volume here while
Adam is telling me about a girl he broke
up with because he didn't like her name
her last name first name her first name
her first name or her last name
today's yes we got a lot of things to
cover we got Elizabeth pip going the
house who's a former model 2016 Trump
campaign staffer who was the founder
and president
of The Exodus movement which is
committed to fighting the rising
anti-americanism and anti-Semitism of
the far left as well as promoting
support for Israel thanks good to have
you on the podcast yeah thanks for
having me so tell us your story tell the
audience your story a little bit okay
it's a long story but I'm gonna attempt
give us a shorter version of it yes um I
grew up a daughter of immigrants from
the former Soviet Union very proud
Russian Jew in New York City went to
Orthodox School synagogue the whole nine
yards everything my family could not do
back in the Soviet Union
um around 11 years old I discovered that
I wanted to be an Olympic figure skater
which was very random my mom being the
best person in the world moved me to
Florida to the only coaches that were
willing to train me I skated about six
years 10 hours a day the whole nine was
asked to go to the Olympics for 2014 for
the team of Israel then I destroyed my
ankle and was told I would never walk
again
took me some time to get my life
together right
um moved back to New York City I was
discovered by a photographer signed with
Willamina models in a few months I went
back to school and modeling and somehow
ended up in politics and now I'm trying
to combine all of that together how did
that happen how do you go from modeling
to politics because those two typically
don't Collide figure skating
right topic right what's that movie
topic well Cutting Edge The Cutting Edge
yes
that was a great movie Cutting Edge is
that former model you can't say yeah
yeah
I got it girl I mean I still got it yeah
who with who are you modeling with right
now um I have two agencies one here and
One in Atlanta and I'm actually
I'm actually let's go
those are my politics and modeling how
did that happen
um I worked for Donald Trump in 2016 on
problematic right only a little only a
little um on his presidential campaign
uh somehow ended up there and kept that
a giant secret so I can continue
modeling obviously Secrets nowadays do
not last I came out
um ended up in politics 45 of working
women 25 to 40. he's like this no that's
that's the last that's the left trying
to interrupt her from she's on Instagram
as soon as she said she's supposed you
were saying so you you it was a secret
then it got a secret I got out um a lot
of people I think on the right we're
very excited that like a young Jewish
woman was I guess on their side and
wanted to utilize that still not
thrilled about a lot of the
opportunities that came my way but I
tried to make the best of it
um and then realized I think I'm a
little more centered than I originally
thought but somehow I was allowed into
that world and given a giant platform
and now I'm trying to combine it in a
way where I can still model and do
politics and whatever else I wanted so
I'm curious so tell me like what was you
know as somebody who's modeling you're
in that world uh you know I have friends
I'm from La so I have a lot of friends
that are in that world and it's you got
to kind of follow the rules and
guidelines of what they have how did you
all of a sudden say I like what this guy
has to say Trump and and what's the
transition into now wanting to become a
little more independent
uh so the first transition I was in New
York um I lived a few blocks from Trump
Tower I had known who Donald Trump was
because he um ran Walman rank I believe
Brandon owned the figure skating or the
ice skating rink that I started skating
at when I was 10 or 11. very strategic
move yeah right so that's the only thing
I knew about him honestly um I had seen
him like give out medals at one of our
competitions you literally knew nothing
else about him but I knew that and the
fact that he had a TV show that a lot of
my friends watched but I never watched
Donald was the guy that owned a place
that we go to and that's about it that's
Mr Duncan place he built the skating
rink that the city was unable to build
apparently a very big deal
all if you look at like any of my
skating photos when I was like 10 or 11
just like the giant were a trump behind
me
um on the right because he likes to put
his name on stuff obviously so that was
all I knew
um I thought he was different and cool
and angry and as someone who was told
for six years that I was never going to
skate again but wanting to get back on
the ice I thought it was pretty special
watching a guy kind of be laughed at
every day just tell the world he's going
to be president despite being at one
percent in the polls and I think that
kind of that got me and that was that
was it the fact that he was an underdog
yeah so it wasn't even policies you
related to the fact that he was a fight
so then you go and you're like okay I'm
gonna help this you know be part of the
campaign and then at one point are you
kind of like yeah I'm really not a
republican I'm more of an independent
what happened there
I think growing up in New York City
realizing I was more right than a lot of
people I thought I was right-wing or
like right-leaning but it turns out just
if you're a Centrist in New York you're
assumed to be right-leaning that was all
um I like that he was pro-america I'll
give him that like when I was first
starting out it was like America first
and that's it
um and I like that he was another dog
like that was just like the Underdog
Story because I needed that in my life
um I think I met a lot of people around
him that were more right than him but I
still kind of see him as a Centrist and
I think when compared now even to
DeSantis people are starting to realize
he's possibly even more electable than a
lot of people on the right I'm sure
we'll talk about that as well but I
don't see him as right as I think a lot
of people do I definitely don't see
myself that way either but interesting
it's like a weird space to be and I
think to be common sense nowadays
because you're assumed let me ask you a
question about New York Elizabeth so I
just was there this weekend and uh I
love New York
um but for a weekend right so you said
that for New York you were you thought
you were right wing it just turns out
you're a common sense right you know
moderate normal person uh a lot of
people are fleeing New York these days
at what 30 billion dollars of tax
revenue left over the last few years we
just had Rudy Giuliani on the podcast
what two weeks ago the mayor who cleaned
up New York City
uh in New York City I I mean maybe it's
because I'm just conscious of it these
days
there's so much uh LGBT Flags going
around I saw trans like just apparently
just you just they're out there the
trans communities out there just
trying stomping
um
my question to you is like so
you're moderate but in New York you're
you would probably be considered
right-wing Maga crazy yeah you're you're
you'd be a lunatic there but how do you
grapple that right like the lunacy seems
to be coming from that side of the aisle
yet you're the bigot you're the you're
you're the weirdo just for just being a
normal person how do you deal with that
um I mean I don't mind it honestly it's
like a weird space to be in because
there's people I'll talk to here who
think I'm like way too far left so I
don't mind it it's kind of nice I go
back and forth quite a bit so I don't
mind the balance I think I get pretty
sick of it if I stayed in one spot and
like realized how much I didn't fit in
but I feel like the whole country is
just secretly a country of Outsiders so
I don't mind it at all and I don't feel
like you should get bogged down because
in the center of like New York City the
center of the entire world there's a lot
of people that might disagree with you
because if you go anywhere at the left
or the right they're going to be on your
side so I'm curious I know it's not
appropriate question to ask but I think
it's public you're how old 1995. you're
June 26th get out of here that's um
Brooklyn's birthday yeah my daughter's
yeah awesome our anniversary as well
June 26th okay so your 27 about to be 28
okay so 27 the Harvard Extension Harvard
University of Pennsylvania are you doing
Wharton or are you going just to UPenn
um I'm at the school of social policy
and practice I might have my last class
tonight actually you're done with that
really yeah congratulations so here's my
question for you because we don't know
what it's like all our ages start with
the number four and some of us would
like to say starts with a number three
but it's all four we're all in the force
here fully committed he just turned 40
for the third time yeah for the third
time yeah so it happened again but but
the question is the final one you said I
was you know you know I was more you
know Trump camp and this this that I
realize I'm not a republican than
independent uh is anything with school
teachers today that you're still in
school or they have they influenced any
of your policies or your views while
you're going to school in a season like
this
I don't think my views because I've
gotten very lucky with doing school
partially online taking my time taking a
little longer than I should have
um obviously doing work on the side that
would probably change my mind about
anything they would tell me but I've
seen I mean the things I've seen in
school I don't want to say anything as
I'm still in school right now but I mean
you can't it's very hard to escape
without being completely radicalized
like every class has some kind of
undertone of everything everything yeah
so so that's the part you know so what
are some examples of that like when you
say the undertone how much of it is
under the surface how much is this
full-on explicit what what have you
experienced I mean the
pixel students very explicit um before I
went to Penn I spoke to like an Alum
because I was very curious about like
the anti-israel sentiment on campus and
I mean she boarded me kind of what I was
kind of expecting but a little afraid of
um I think that's the worst part like
the anti-Semitism anti-israel bias that
part's really scary I think Colombia and
NYU are some of the worst in the country
which is crazy because New York is full
of Jews that's kind of all I knew I
didn't know how few Jews there were in
the country growing up in New York
because I thought everyone was Jewish so
that's pretty scary but I mean it's it's
hard it's every single class and it's
from current events to like you know Roe
versus Wade being overturned meaning
that we're mourning in class instead of
studying to literally literally to uh
that's what we don't know we were
mourning when Tupac died
the teacher even was sitting there so
what a sad day I think my friend at NYU
said when Trump won in 16 they all were
black to school for two weeks because it
was America's funeral wasn't it yeah and
they literally started bringing in
emotional Port like Ponies and like
literally they brought on the head like
sessions
one of our girls here said that she lost
friends because she didn't post uh
why don't you post this like what do you
mean why didn't I post it's almost like
the pressure to have to post it yeah you
know my kids right now are going through
the age where
uh there's bullying going on okay
and you know
Dylan doesn't get bullied you're not
going he's choked me out there Dylan's
the one that is the the kid everybody
wants to be friends with yeah yeah
because he's like if you're friends with
Dylan you're scored away he gets the
girls he gets all that stuff that's
Dylan he's got the energy Senna is the
center of all attention you know she's
like in the class she's a girlfriend
everybody wants to have so send us
friends are the pretty friends and all
this stuff Brooklyn is home kicking it
with Melbourne Papa she's chilling right
yeah but Tico is going through the phase
at 11 years old where things are
happening people are saying things
conversations are being had it's being
pushed he's coming home he's asking the
questions why do they say this why is
this happening and you have to know if a
person comes home today and they don't
have somebody to talk to to reason with
most of the time unless if this kid has
got a strong backbone character at that
age you're gonna cave because your
entire Mo in school when you're younger
is to what to conform and to be popular
you want to be cool you want people to
like you you want to be like man they
don't like me well she said I'm stupid
you know she said what a dumb thing and
I know you're like oh my God she said
that and he said this so you're so much
trying to join the club and imagine like
even if when we went to school how much
do you remember when we went to school
how much do you remember politics being
involved zero I don't I didn't since and
because me and power both in the in the
in the military I didn't know what left
or right or anything was until I got out
and I moved to Los Angeles then I was
like holy [__] like the Trump situation
made me go oh my God is it that is it
that bad that they don't want to lose
that that control in that power I did
you hear anything in school I don't
remember I mean listen it would happen
some things would happen and you know
people would make their comments but you
know to be everybody dresses black in
school because of what happened Trump
and Roe v Wade everybody's morning
instead of it is a it's got to be a
weird season today the one lady I'm
talking to uh who's uh one of the most
powerful Recruiters in the insurance
industry she's the executive she hires
c-suites for companies so she hires all
the C Suites for companies we're having
a conversation I said you know I have to
battle right now she's a little older
than me your kids are in their 20s I see
you know the the challenge with
parenting today is the goal is to make
sure you don't screw your kids up too
much okay because it's like you're
you're having to deal with how hard it
is to be a parent today but it's got to
be even much harder to be a kid today oh
my God from the angles you're being
targeted was it like that for you in
high school as well or not really
um I went to high school online because
I just wanted to tell you but in middle
school I was bullied really badly not
over politics but I mean I ate lunch in
the bathroom for months like I was
really bullied so thinking back now if
that ended up being political I don't
know what I probably would have done
just to get to eat lunch with my is that
toughen you up a little bit I think so
okay well I mean listen it is what it is
favorite figure skating movie
I mean ice princess Ice Princess yeah
okay I've never had that many to choose
from yeah oh and then favorite figure
skaters there's somebody that you you
know like he's a Russian skater named
plushenko who's the reason I started
skating wow wow okay yeah there's a uh I
remember there's a picture of me and uh
uh Mary Lou Retton and I'm introducing
her uh and I remember I'm standing next
to her I'm like Mary Lou Retton she was
like I don't know how tall she is she's
gonna be like four ten or four gymnasts
they're even smaller than yeah yeah but
who's the one uh mogachini uh what's the
one Dominica Luciano Dominica she's a
gymnast as well yeah you got your sports
yeah she follows the podcast she follows
the podcast on Twitter we go back and
forth no but Mary Lou Retton tiny our
figure skaters also tiny like uh they're
pretty small okay you're not small
though no it wasn't good for me I was
supposed to do pairs actually because I
was so tiny yeah and then after I got
injured I came back back and I'd grown
probably like 10 inches and gained like
80 pounds and I realized all that was
out the window done done so hike doesn't
help in that world after five two you're
pretty screwed yeah well it helps in
modeling right completely different
space I'm like a tiny bit too short for
that and then Too Tall so you're right
in the middle yeah so that's why you go
into politics yes where I'm also right
in the middle
yeah but some people would say you also
think Trump's in the middle and and that
would drive some people insane today
people that's why it's funny people
think Rogan is a republican today he's
far right someone said that to me
yesterday they're like yeah that guy Joe
Rogan he's like super strong like far
right guy I'm like Joe Rogan
he was a Bernie Sanders supporter but we
we showed this on the podcast the other
day with the the cartoon stick figure
thing with Elon Musk yeah about
basically how far the left has gone and
you can make the case that some of the
people on the right have also a little
far gone but I think if you're comparing
Apples to Apples yeah this thing right
here the left has kind of lost their
mind a lot of times this thing right
here
2008 tweets about American I mean can
you scroll in on that punch in
Center yeah
so nothing's changed it's just a lot has
changed but Center went to the right and
a bunch of the people on the left are
kind of like now seen as Republicans you
constantly hear things like if JFK was a
candidate today you'd be Republican
let's hit somebody show with Bill
Clinton with that we're going to some
issues I'm okay okay so first issue I
want to hit up is what happened with you
and your uh ex over the weekend Chelsea
Handler so this is pretty wild uh you
you text me in the middle of the night
yeah and I look at this I'm like you got
to be kidding me so apparently Adam has
triggered Chelsea Handler where her team
made a video edited with Adam responding
to Adam as an alpha man and you should
see what she had to say uh Rob please
play this clip and we'd like to get a
little bit of reaction easily change
three men in their 40s yeah and somebody
in their 20s you're easily triggered
don't watch go ahead go ahead play this
45 of working women ages 25 to 45
by 2030 we'll be non-married no kids
single okay so you might say well what's
wrong with that okay
I'll tell you what's wrong with that
nothing I usually don't do things like
this but when I have to listen to men
talk like that I have no choice but to
sedate myself with drugs and alcohol
lately I've been loud and proud about my
status as a single unmarried childless
wild woman and apparently some men
cannot handle that every time I go on
Instagram I stumble upon sde morons like
this guy pontificating about how unhappy
women like me must be if you think that
you're going to be 45 years old no kids
not married and that you're gonna
genuinely be fulfilled in life because
you made money best of luck to you honey
right now best of luck to you honey that
clip was to an Instagram account called
alphabet from motivation zero you got
the Zero part right anybody that follows
that account is getting zero Pikachu I'm
sorry but if the child free Joyride I'm
on triggers you here's a hint if you
need Daily Alpha content to remind you
to be Alpha you might not be an alpha
take it from an alpha and the truth is
studies show that single women live
longer and are
you want to know why because they wake
up every day and they don't have to
listen to like you anyway I have to go
because my single unmarried ass is about
to perform at my sold out comedy show
I'd invite you but there are no tickets
left bye wow yeah wow so what was your
first reaction when you saw that by the
way well does anything scream I'm so
happy at chugging vodka at 9am I'm so
happy with my life as I'm funneling
vodka yeah as soon as I wake up yeah so
clearly she's triggered clearly if I'm
in her position right now I'm doing
everything I can to justify my life's
decisions yeah and it's it's one of
those things where don't get mad at me
Chelsea Handler get mad at the facts all
I was doing was reading report from
Morgan Stanley pretty credible Source
they gave a report called the Shi
economy right not the economy the Shi
economy and essentially what they did
was State some facts about how modern
day feminism has I guess empowered women
to you know work get that bag make that
money that's great but what are the
ramifications of those those decisions
well the ramifications is you might end
up
like Chelsea Handler alone single no man
in your life and just banging a bunch of
random dudes that you meet on hinge and
Ryan Bumble and if that's what you want
out of your life follow the Chelsea
Handler path but if you want to be a
beautiful feminine woman like our friend
over here today maybe you balance having
a career but also understanding that you
should also be a feminine beautiful
woman last point
she called herself take it from an alpha
uh no dude wants an alpha chick with
packing bde telling him what to do and I
responded on Twitter and if we could
pull that up I said maybe that's why
guys like 50 Cent uh joke and the chef
whatever I forget the Bobby Flay
basically hit it and quit it because
yeah they'll bang you out Chelsea yeah
but they're not gonna wipe you up and at
the end of the day I think that is the
the the what a woman is looking for news
flash honey men don't want Alpha chicks
with bde maybe that's why 50 Cent Bobby
Flay and joyke hit it and quit it at 48
your beauty and humor for sure have
faded you drown yourself with alcohol
and drugs to sedate your sorrow and then
I took a line from Wedding Crashers now
go comatose for me baby what do you
think about this that was a lot
it was
um I don't know about the hitting and
quitting it situation I'm not a guy
that's possible
um I don't know I got married when I was
very young and people seemed very
unhappy about that well you're still
married I am so married I know right I
didn't say I didn't say happily
still an opportunity
I was 23. people thought I was
absolutely bad [__] most people thought
I was pregnant which I was not
um I don't know I think it's weird I
think the entire world seems to be very
big on encouraging people to do things
that might make them feel better about
themselves so that everyone can be
miserable together like that kind of
seems like what it is from like Middle
School people are bullying me people
really don't like when anyone does
something that might make them happy or
different because they want everyone to
be miserable together you know
by the way do you know her story do you
know what happened to her when she was a
kid Chelsea yeah do you know what
happened to when she was a kid so
apparently so I was actually like
curious to know like why is this girl so
you know she does not seem happy and
then you see some of her clips
happy people don't try to convince
people they're happy right you know how
somebody who is uh uh what happened Adam
no he's pulling up you know how somebody
is you know trying so hard to convince
you that they're good or they're happy
or they're successful or they're smart
there's typically a very deep insecurity
pain there's something there right so
for example you ask Michael the question
who's the greatest of all time Michael
says it's unfair because there's a lot
of different guys that came before me he
never says I'm the greatest of all time
you asked LeBron LeBron says what I'm
the greatest okay it's a different
perspective
this girl's brother died at seven or
eight years old and a family had such a
hard time with it that apparently they
stopped you know paying attention to her
and she went through that pain as a kid
of what happened there okay so you don't
become like this by accident she's gone
through numbers of therapy sessions
Conan O'Brien had Iran talking about why
did you have a guy pee on you in the
middle of the ocean and you post a video
there's a video that came out live about
her with uh you know sex tape and all
this stuff I really wanted to be out
there this is an older tape you know
it's almost like uh
a person you talk to that offends you
first in case you are gonna make them
feel bad to kind of you know belittle
you to feel better about themselves you
can't feel like she's going through it
and quite frankly here's a challenge
how many followers does she have go to
her uh account Twitter how many
followers or just click on a link what
is it 7.8 million yeah 7.6 million she
gets a lot of eyeballs a lot of people
follow her she's admired by people from
that space if you actually go to the
tweet that she tweeted and read the
comments under her so go to the video
that she tweeted and watch the comments
so it's not like she's alone here zoom
in a little bit
so is he wearing a suit uh to a misogyny
discussion oh man okay there you go the
first one the reason I chose to be
single is because of men like this
there's an overwhelmingly large number
of men would uh what is it
maturity of what is it maturity maturity
of babies who think it is my job to be
the mother is it shocking I would choose
fun vacations doing stuff with friends
and making money over that
and then some guy responds back LOL you
let random men online dictate how you
live your life remember your interview
with uh kumani and all you could do is
focus on the facts that he's a Muslim if
uh it was strange anyways so there's a
lot of people I'm almost 49 childless
unmarried and quite happy to not have to
pick up after a jerk off jerk man jerk
what man I have my dog and cat for the
company and I have it I mean that's the
world I have my dog and my cat as long
as she's got a vibrator she's happy as
hell but that's the comment right there
she said and that comes from True Adam
you guys know this one you're she was on
the Chelsea Handler show which was like
successful and she was out used to be
very funny
hilarious the writers were dope
everything was on point once that window
closes then you got nothing going on
you're sitting there drinking she has to
come at people like you to make herself
roll up again I'm really good friends
with Joe Coy and I think that whole
going on tour with him and we were
dating and everything was just a big up
her name to draw his audience now she's
selling out places again because of that
so that's how Hollywood Works bro she's
not relevant now she's relevant again
nobody cares about what she does with I
generally don't care live your life get
married don't get married I literally
can't
that's why I don't wake up and think
about Chelsea Handler but who I do care
about are the women that I speak to we
all know I do a show sawscast that I
interview
hundreds of wide variety types of women
I've had women in their 40s break down
in tears crying basically saying I'm
alone and my eggs are frozen I don't
have a man I used to be hot now guys
don't look at me the same I was fed a
crock of [__] by feminism okay but
taking it a step further I also
interview a ton of model volleyball that
I was just at I was just we did rolling
loud we did Ultra we just did Tortuga
interview a ton of women who are all in
their early 20s in their mid-20s and
they're going down this path I don't
need no man I don't like all that and to
see the writing on the wall of what the
future will hold I think is what I'm
most concerned about nobody gives a [__]
about what Chelsea does with her life
it's the fact that her eight million
followers or whoever's going to her show
are going to be fed this bull crap and I
when I see women cry break down wish
that they had a better life than what
they have now I think that's the biggest
problem by the way do you have that clip
about her day in the life of a modern
family we played it a couple months ago
a month ago I don't want to play it
again we played it it's pretty that to
me is cringe is indicative of what's
going on she wakes up at six a.m she
says she takes an edible masturbates
goes back to bed at noon then she flies
to Paris and she meets a random dude on
Raya bangs him then you know just lives
her life then she basically puts on a VR
set of goggles goes into the metaphor
she's not a real person yeah she's she's
she does this stuff
for to capitalize on an audience to make
money the problem is if you're if you're
a gal who's just an accountant and
you're focused on your career and you're
43 and you follow Chelsea yeah nobody
cares about you you just you go home to
your dog your cat your vibrator and
that's your life and you know when this
is gonna catch up on her when she's in
her let's say 70s 80s hopefully she
lives that long and she's not feeling
well there's shit's going downhill no
kids are going to be there no husband's
gonna be there to help her who are you
going to go to he's gonna just have help
that you pay for when you want somebody
that loves you and is genuinely caring
for you to be there to help you because
that what did she she's almost 50. she's
four it ain't y'all it's happening she's
49. yeah because vodka that's what vodka
does that's exactly well you know this
goes back to a deeper issue remember the
Wall Street Journal uh story we talked
about the decline in American values
yeah right yeah about not wanting kids
not wanting families
and I I kind of I think it's important
for you to respond to this so somebody
said okay Adam so you're saying she's
this she's in her 40s is that she has no
kids she has no this you're in your 40s
you're not married you have no kids why
can you judge her but people cannot
judge you that was a question I was
asked I think it's a very good question
for you to respond I think that's a I
get that question all the time are you
basically saying that men and women are
the same I think it takes uh a while it
takes years for a man to mature to reach
his status you know they say that men
are success objects and women are Beauty
objects by the time you're 40 Chelsea
your beauty has faded no have you ever
seen the sexual market value chart men
are judged on their resources their
money their age their income their game
their personality there's a whole host
of things that men are judged on okay
women eighty percent of the chart is
their beauty yeah news flash guys like
pretty women all right you're a model
congratulations like you wouldn't be
modeling if guys found you unattractive
the that's what men are judged on and I
speak to so many young guys out there
that are 19 20 25 they haven't hit their
Market women aren't paying attention to
them they have no money they have no
game they have nothing I'm like dude it
takes time to marinate women reach their
success on the front end okay I know
plenty of girls in Miami that are 21 25
who basically get invited on Yachts
billionaires Yachts just because they're
pretty I'm sure you've been there you're
on Palm Beach you get it no dudes are
getting invited on Yachts you need to
work your ass off to buy the [__]
yacht yep okay so men and women are not
the same and the difference is my
Outlook my perspective I'm not that dude
being like I'm single bro all I do is
Smash and that's what I want to do the
rest of my life it's like no I've had my
fun I've done it all I've made money
I've made connections now I'm actually
looking for the next phase of life so no
the two are not the same at 43 now I'm
at my Peak money financial status my
work and now I have what is known as
options Chelsea is completely out of art
are you are you saying are you saying
she's your type is that kind of
interesting maybe 20 years ago you like
her and is it like do we need to say
Chelsea if you're watching this I would
love to have a conversation with you
it's free it would be great for you the
chance of me wifing up a 48 year old has
been Chelsea Handler is non-existent if
she has a younger 24 year old sister
holler okay all right so any comments
from your end or can we skip to the next
story no we should skip Let's Get
Serious we have to put that out one
thing here yeah
gonna cut this up and be like
he's so much women I love women I hang
out with women my best friends are women
like other than my actual guy friends my
co-host and my show female I love women
I get along with women I'm friends with
women this is not misogyny okay it's I
want to see the best for women and I
don't think Chelsea Handler's outcome is
the best for women okay good get it off
your chest it's it I'm gonna say woosa
you sound a little like Donald Trump
I love that Bob I grabbed them yeah yeah
you know what all right okay so let's
grab this next story here Kanye West who
lost Fortune after anti-semitic tirade
says he likes Jewish people again that's
kind of good news
this is an Instagram post yeah it was an
Instagram post I think this is mine
already Nick Fuentes was paid apparently
thirty thousand dollars by Kanye West
presidential campaign and that's a story
that just came in when is this that's
yesterday the hill so let me read this
story to you and see what your thoughts
are on this so uh Nick Fuentes was paid
30k by Kanye West presidential campaign
Federal Election Commission filings
revealed that 2020 presidential campaign
of rapper Kanye West was a paid far
right activists and white supremacist
Nick Fuentes over thirty thousand
dollars for uh uh archival services and
a travel reimbursement according to data
from a Federal Election Commission year
launched uh a long shot run for
president 2020 alongside former
president Donald Trump despite openly
being a trump supporter and earn about
60 000 votes on Election Day Fuentes has
been labeled a white supremacist by the
justice department and is known for his
racist racist anti-semitic rhetoric
Connie has also come under Fire for
anti-Semitic what are your thoughts on
the story
um I knew that Fuentes was working for
him I think we all kind of saw that
break a few months ago um Fuentes is an
absolute monster like truly I think I've
seen a few of his Clips
um explaining in terms of like cookies
in an oven how six million Jews could
not have possibly perished in the
Holocaust that's just the beginnings of
the things that he says so he's
absolutely just despicable I don't want
to know how we got to Kanye I don't know
what happened to Kanye I was a giant fan
um of Kanye's growing up and up until
recently uh listen to his music all the
time I loved skating to it and working
out to it and really yeah he was kind of
like the underdog inspiration in his own
way as well always yes I've Loved Kanye
forever so very disappointing um I
launched a Holocaust Education project
in honor of this whole situation called
uh you can find it educate kanye.com but
yeah it was really disappointing I think
he's going through something because
normal people do not not only want to
associate with Fuentes but want to hire
him to make him president so it doesn't
make a lot of sense I think if
something's off or sick then we should
just let him get help but do you think
Connie can do anything to uh because
apparently this whole story about him
watching Jonah Hill you know whatever 21
Jump Street and kind of changed my mind
like dude like Jewish people again all
this stuff and this was a story about a
month ago or three weeks ago do you
think you know he can do anything to get
back to who he was before or is this
a permanent career you know done
decision that's going to ruin them for
years and years to come
he can come back hey America loves
another dog but I think people love when
people grow up apologize
um take responsibility and move on and I
think this is a very easy thing to
apologize for you know there's no reason
he can't say hey really was going
through something had no idea the
garbage that was coming out of these
people's mouths I apologize and I'll
visit Holocaust Museum I'll focus on
writing music and making amends and take
it from there one day at a time is it
kind of like if he wrote a song instead
of Jesus walked he says Jesus never
walked
to see what happens so so there is a
possibility that in the future you could
figure skate and listen to his music
again
yeah I mean possibly that's a tough one
you don't sound committed to it he was
he's known for his music he's not known
for politician Kanye West so I will
always admire his music okay Adam any
thoughts on this one yeah of course Nick
Fuentes Nick Fuentes specifically
um well
I just covered a story that he did with
my friend Pearl uh Pearla Davis pearly
things massive YouTuber
um in the manosphere red pill space and
she invited him on the show and listen
when you uh when you play stupid games
you win stupid prizes and you sit down
with a guy like Nick Fuentes who is 24
and now he's the expert on the Holocaust
right okay uh by the way it's
interesting that Kanye is able to thread
the needle of because uh white
supremacist anti-semite so it's like
Kanye will you know he'll tune out the
anti-semitic stuff I'm sorry tune out
the anti-black stuff but just kind of
focus on the anti-semitic stuff it's
like I know you hate blacks and Jews and
dogs but I'm just going to focus on the
Jewish part with you to their uh Nick so
uh Nick I think actually reached out
what was the situation Rob so I
basically responded to Pearl and I was
basically like look Pearl stay in your
lane you know if you want to be in the
dating red pill space you know why get
into debates over the merits of slavery
or the accuracy of
slavery and the Holocaust it's like
what's gonna what's the benefit for your
specific career do you know what this
girl is Pearl Davis I don't know okay
I'm sure you've seen her online take a
picture but I basically was like you
know your reputation is who you are even
if it's not who you are so Nick you ever
seen this girl
oh yeah she's like okay gotcha
um so Eve and I think Nick said hey I'm
not a white supremacist what was the
response well Nick's Camp reached out
and they wanted to see if you'd be
interested in sitting down with them um
the the quote was he's being smeared as
a white supremacist by Adam uh but I am
one of many examples of proof to the
contrary as I am a black man and this
was his uh middleman and what is fun
says what he's that's a Latin last name
right he's Latino and he's okay and he's
just saying outlandish [__] yeah well
it's not like I put the word white
supremacist out there you have Wikipedia
the guy Wikipedia it's the first thing
the American white supremacist political
commentator yeah so all I'm doing is
reading I'm not defending the guy at all
whatsoever but be careful when you're
the you know sane just because uh
Wikipedia says something about somebody
that that's who they are that's not how
I judge it what what has happened is if
these stories are surrounding you
there's a reason for for it some of it
is probably because you're trying to get
eyeballs and I saw him I think in one
clip if this is the same guy that he was
following Ben Shapiro while he's a
crossing the crossing the street with
his kids I think is is it the same guy
okay yeah listen if you're doing that to
get the eyeballs great uh it's you work
them it's working for you people are
talking about you but there's certain
things you know
I don't know if you want certain things
to be your identity out there so maybe
you can come on a podcast yet you guys
can talk to each other look maybe I'll
bring him down to the Holocaust Museum
in Miami Beach and we'll sit down and
have a cup of coffee right there or we
can go to the Holocaust museum in
Washington DC and let's see if that's
something that he'd be open to maybe
you'd like to join us sure okay we'll
discuss yeah okay so let's talk about uh
Trump and DeSantis I know as a uh uh
model and somebody that goes to
University of Pennsylvania and you're
about to graduate tonight your last
class are you comfortable talking about
this or could you get an F if you give
commentary on it so let's get right into
it Trump holds wider wide lead over
DeSantis among Georgia GOP voters in
2024 primary poll despite the
ex-president's endorsement flops against
top state Republicans last year okay so
this is a story from The Insider that
just came out uh let me read some of the
highlights of this story here so okay so
Paul of likely Republican primary voice
on Georgia found that a former president
Donald Trump leads a former Governor Ron
DeSantis 51-31 51-30 in a potential 2024
race the survey also found that Trump
retains an average with the party's most
conservative voters as well as those who
are older and those who do not have a
college degree the Santas perform better
in the poll among Republican college
graduates and was competitive with the
uh Trump among higher income members of
the party the polls showed that 89 of
GOP voters said the recent indictment of
Trump by the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office over his involvement
in a hush money payment to the adult
film actress Stormy Daniels shouldn't
bar him from seeking the presidency
again what are your thoughts uh when it
comes down to Trump and the sentence for
2024. I have a lot of thoughts um just
because I live here and this is all
anyone ever wants to talk about for some
reason
um I think the Santos is severely over
hyped um I think people really want to
move on from Donald Trump on both sides
even those that love him I think
secretly dream about a time where they
can go to work and not be asked about
their opinion on Donald Trump
um I think people think the status is
that guy because after 2016 people still
don't understand why Trump won and
really want someone to be the next
something and they think a republican
with five percent of Trump's personality
could do that they think the Santa's is
the guy I don't see it I don't think
this is going to last I think the
indictment unfortunately it's probably
one of the first indictments Trump's
going to see we saw what happened to his
poll numbers after that and I think
that's what we're going to see for the
next year okay so you're you're 27
you're about to finish you know uh MBA
is it you know you're getting your
message you're about to finish your
Masters you're married you're living in
Palm Beach and New York back and forth
what policies what matters to you the
most today when it comes down to a
candidate so if you were to say at this
age where I am who I am this is what
matters to me you know I want to see
this this what would those items be for
you those policies be
honestly it's weird if you asked me six
months ago I could list a bunch and now
I'm just like let's not go into war with
Russia and China like I'm just scared
for what the hell is going to happen to
America and I want whatever comes after
Joe Biden to actually protect those from
the world which really wants us dead
like it's that simple so I'd say whoever
can keep America safe and keep a country
in existence for my future children
that's number one right now what's two
I
um I don't think they're in order I'd
say foreign policy wise America First
very simple um when it comes to in the
country I think
for example keeping something like
abortion like I consider myself Pro uh
life but I think keeping Americans kind
of stable and not arguing over how far
left or how far right we can be based on
whose administration is in power like
that's a normal thing that we should be
able to agree on I think the Santa is
too far right on that for example we
just saw that six weeks yeah um I think
I think Trump actually said when I could
be wrong when Texas passed the six week
the same rule I think Trump said it was
a little complex and he wasn't sure if
he agreed with it so I think it was 2021
I believe yeah I think a balance is very
necessary I think people really want to
see the right beat the left or left beat
the right depending on you know what
side you're on I just want a normal
country I want to balance I want Harmony
I want people not you know punching each
other in the street based on who they
voted for in 2016.
um and I want to know that you know
people are safe the kids are safe the
religious liberty is safe just very
basic Common Sense American values that
I grew up with that I'm kind of scared
or disappearing so let me read that
story for you and and I want to I want
to get your comment thoughts on this
Florida lawmakers passed six-speak
abortion law this is a Wall Street
Journal story uh they have passed a bill
Banning abortion after six weeks of
pregnancy a strict measure that
indicates Republicans aren't backing
away from efforts to curtail abortion
access even in the states where such
efforts may carry political risk a poll
in March by the University of North
Carolina found that 75 percent of
Floridians oppose Banning abortion
starting at six weeks of pregnancy all
by with no exceptions of for for rape
and incest the final hurdle for the bill
is a signature from Governor Ron
DeSantis who has said he would sign
legislation limiting abortion if it
crosses his desk if enacted the bill
would ban most abortions in the state
and with limited exceptions including
for rape and incest and for certain
medical emergencies since the Supreme
Court overturned Roe v Wade last year
June roughly a dozen states have banned
most abortions so you're not with six
weeks I think majority of Americans with
not mistaken are uncomfortable with that
they are yeah yeah it's that simple
Americans don't support this you know
when you want an America that's living
in Harmony and when issues are that
serious and that nuanced and that
emotion over so many people I don't
think the whole like beat the left beat
the right you know debate and wokeness
and you know social media going viral
like all these things that politicians
are focusing on right now I don't think
that's necessary for an issue as serious
as abortion you think that's going to be
a big talk topic of discussion for 2024.
you think left's going to use that a lot
depending on who the nominee is but yes
for sure let's just say an energized guy
named Joe Biden is the nominee and he's
going up against a trump or with the
sentence how different would it be
um I think if the santis is the nominee
with the six week you know ban I think
would be more prevalent but no people
are going to bring it up for sure I
think that was a big topic of the
midterms we kind of realized I mean I
see it going on on college campuses I
see what's happening with young people
and that's I'd say their top three
issues like abortion is one of them
college is a university that you're
talking about they're talking about
abortion yeah well don't forget uh just
during the midterms uh it was supposed
to be a red wave yeah right I mean for
months and months and months it's a red
wave we all this always happens the
incumbent president when the when he's
in there and the the the there's a
midterm election and then what we saw
happen was a red teardrop basically so
they took over the the House
Representatives they didn't do anything
with the Senate and one of the major
reasons why was this Dobbs decision
overturning Rover's Wade yeah uh you
know there's speculation that Mitch
McConnell manufactured this because he
didn't want to take over that's [__]
I think this was uncalculated in a
horrible decision by the Republicans
they should have waited until after the
midterms do this so clearly this is a
major issue especially for women now if
when it comes to DeSantis in Florida
this makes no sense to me because if
you're if you're if you're trying to win
a primary okay
um
you maybe appeal to the base okay maybe
that works for you but we all know that
basically the way that it works is
during the primary you appeal to your
base and then you pivot in the general
election to appeal to the center
nobody in America there is no appetite
for a six week abortion ban there's no
appetite we can have conversations about
12 weeks 15 weeks pro-life poor
pro-choice nobody this is Draconian at
best not nobody it's not nobody it's
just not the majority so so it's not a
nobody thing when you say that and the
Mitch McConnell you don't know if that
did happen or not as a strategy nobody
knows that nobody can sit there and say
that wasn't the case we're all
speculating here these are our opinions
that we're given it's not 100 certainty
that we know one way or another
to do what what is kind of weird is
after what happened with Roe v Wade
everybody in the country already knows
where the Santa stands you don't need to
do this like this is not a a policy to
attack to get the conservative people to
say oh he's even more conservative than
I thought I you know I don't know if
this is the right direction to go but
you know he's choosing to go why do you
think he's doing this like you're if
you're his strategist if you're his
chief strategist and you're saying all
right you got to run to the right of
Center but everyone's saying the reason
that people like you is because you're
quote unquote left of trump right right
of trump why would you do this this
makes no sense to me yeah he also did it
didn't he sign at like 11 p.m where he
knows it's not going to be possible he's
not a stupid guy why would you do this
Pat six weeks
why would he do this yeah why would he
do this okay you're you're either doing
this because it's truly a belief that
you have and let's just say that's what
he really believes in based on his
values and principles they're thinking
this is going to get people that weren't
there for him to support him which I
believe he already has that vote uh
maybe it's a position to differentiate
himself from Trump to say hey I am not
like Trump while Trump is you know
casual with this and he'll go up to
whatever the numbers 12 weeks or you
know 16 weeks 20 weeks you know I'm not
going past six weeks could be a way of
him wanting certain conservative people
to you know say okay this guy is more
conservative than we thought there's so
many different ways you can look at this
here I don't know strategically if this
would be the policy I would
touch if you want to become president
after we saw what happened on midterms I
don't I don't understand it
strategically either but like she said
he's not a dummy he's a very smart guy
uh descent you know who the sentence is
here's what the sentence is you know how
in a group text you're with your friends
and your buddies and everybody's talking
[__] yeah and you're sending texts and
one guy sends a picture of this and you
know how we kind of send stuff to we say
stuff to each other with guys that maybe
you wouldn't you know wouldn't do it you
know you're referring to what is known
as locker room talk well you want to
call a locker room talk with it I would
do this I would do this to her and I
would do that man let me tell you all
this stuff like guys to talk about he's
the guy that would just do one emoji LOL
but he would never say and engage that's
him yeah so you have to know who he is
meaning this guy has been thinking about
this
since he was very young that one day
this is going to happen and he's careful
who he takes pictures with he's careful
he's that guy okay this is not a
trumpers like I don't give a [__] man
I'm doing this I'm doing that you don't
like it I don't know this is so there's
a very different style so if if that's
how he's branding himself
and he decides to get away from that
brand we already have somebody that's
away from that brand yeah your brand is
the opposite of trump okay your brand is
the safe guy your brand is the you know
this is the guy that we settle down with
we have that brand he's very safe but by
the way I think he's a strong leader I
think in a way this also helps knowing
he's probably careful with the decisions
he's going to be making if he does
become a president I think he will make
a good president I think there's a part
of him that he'll make a great president
uh later on it's just you know whether
people are ready with him being there
today and whether this was a good move
at a time like this I don't know you got
20 other issues you can pick and choose
from to go from you can choose the
Border you can choose economy you can
choose covet you can go after more fauci
you can do uh education you can go after
the trends you can do so many different
things this one's going to upset some
people on the right that are pro-choice
so this is and you said it there's a lot
of closet Pro choices by the way on the
right oh 100 Tommy Lauren made her name
there are people that will say I'm
pro-life but inside listen man I kind of
had to be pro-choice seven years ago
there's a lot of closet Pro choices that
none of us know about male politician
ever yeah yeah absolutely yeah but yeah
so Elizabeth if it comes down so so
Trump because you're you're involved
with the campaign right in 2011 yeah so
you obviously saw it firsthand Trump did
not get a fair Shake I don't care what
anybody says before he won the
investigation from Russia the collusion
to during the swamp and the media just
turning on him nobody's ever seen
anything like that because they were all
they all bowed down to the powers that
be if it came down to right now are you
going are you voting for Trump or the
Saints if it comes down to that left or
right from descendants I would vote for
Donald Trump you would 100 go for Donald
Trump and what what and besides all the
like the thing that we just talked about
what what's your just from what you've
seen in the past yeah or are you just
sticking to your guns because you're
like he he is for the people and he
sacrificed everything for us it's like
such a basic non- almost educated answer
but I just I hate politicians like I've
just been around them so much I cannot
stand them and he's a politician and I
don't like that yeah it's that simple
what do you not like about politicians
they're just rehearsed and much like we
just talked about the closeted
pro-choice people like they're just all
horrible like all politicians they'll
tell you what you want to hear it
doesn't matter they'll compromise
anything as long not a statement or like
a decision that comes out of their mouth
that doesn't come from like give us an
example give us an example of it of
somebody I was just gonna say like who
would be the poster child you think so
all of a truly what name did you say I
said to Santos but that's only because
we've talked about now anyone before
Donald Trump anyone asks well she's
saying because he's a politician like
Ted Cruz when you look at Ted Cruz you
look at Ted Cruz he just says what like
he's the typical cutout Board of a
politician he says what the people want
to hear you don't know who he really is
as a human being and she nailed it I
mean Donald Trump was a businessman but
just say you know what I'm gonna come in
I'm going to shake [__] I don't know I
don't think Ted Cruz is likable but I
think he's a dog well he's I don't I
don't think he's you know you know like
I always go back to if we were in high
school right to see who the person was
in high school okay so if you go to high
school this guy you kind of know who he
was okay if I go to high school with you
I kind of know who you were you go to
high school with Ted you know who he was
you know who Ted was yeah who was Ted
Cruz in high school 10 probably on the
debate team he definitely picked up it
was definitely a very unconscious he got
a wedgie a week 100 someone he's
probably guy that was so condescending
making people you know who he is Ted
Cruz a a a a movie character you ready
I'm gonna give it to you and you're
gonna go there ready ready go ahead
Goodwill Hunting how about them apples
he's that guy oh wow really okay do you
know who which guy I'm talking about 100
he's gonna come in here and recite
things that you read online in that boom
boom he is that smart and he wants to
make you look like a [__] but guess
what he is still a dog 100 he is still a
dog but politician through and through I
also understand what no I don't think so
you don't think so no I think
politicians through and through to me is
somebody that
I get what she's saying there's a
difference between a Statesman and you
know a politician there's still a few
them around you don't have to like them
there's still few them around there's
some of them that will sell their soul
just to have their career who would you
say right now if you had to if you had
to say politician that's the person
McConnell is a politician and the
council politics I think it's for sure
politician I think there's a lot of them
out there but I think he's a politician
Schumer's a politician Pelosi is a
politician uh uh the problem with this
world is the longer you're in this world
the more you start being one and you
don't even know it it's that temperature
yeah look if you and I lived in a house
okay
and in this house we're living with 20
different people you and I are 22 years
old okay
we're expected to live in this house for
six months it's on the beach okay 10
girls 10 guys oh wow it's a beautiful
house party house Jersey Shore type
drinks on the house everything on the
house
if 19 other guys in this house are
snorting they're doing e they're rolling
they're doing everything how long until
you are tempted to join the club 10 30
at night
the point is there's power and influence
of course so the longer you're in the
swamp you eventually they call this one
because which is why term limits should
be a number one priority yeah did you
see that guy give a speech uh he was at
the podium and he's like you guys tell
me if this is the NBA or the NFL players
you ever seen this piece oh yeah yeah he
goes all right guys give in to an
audience he's like you tell me which
sport you think this is the NBA of the
NFL is like uh 32 DUIs uh multiple
convictions four seconds go back to it
and play it go ahead yeah yeah this is a
great I know what you're talking about
watch this oh this is oh okay this is
kind of validated
NBA or NFL Elizabeth you ever seen this
go back go back to Chicago
by the way I I want you to guess before
he reveals it whether you think it's the
NBA their NFL okay
which is it is it NBA or NFL
36 have been accused of spousal abuse
seven have been arrested for fraud
19 have been accused of writing bad
checks
117 of directly or indirectly been
bankrupted at least two businesses
three have done time for assault 71 I
repeat 71 cannot get a credit card due
to their bad credit
14 have been arrested on drug related
charges eight have been arrested for
shoplifting 21 currently are defendants
in lawsuits and 84 have been arrested
for drunk driving in the last year
how many of you think NBA
how many of you think NFL which one do
you think Elizabeth do you think it's
the NBA their NFL you're going to say
like United States Congress yeah
it's the 435 members of the United
States yes there you go proving your
point of course yeah
Congress approval ratings actually just
increased five percent over the last
year to a whopping 23 approval we're at
75 disapproval uh
not great numbers no their Q score what
would it take to do term limits I mean
because the people that are they're in
charge of saying yeah the people that
are voting targets but don't you feel
like that I mean that I agree with you
100 like I'm like when you see somebody
like Joe Biden obviously he's the worst
one but Nancy Pelosi actually speak I'm
like you want to talk about embarrassed
I'm like how how
they're all the same Chuck Grassley he's
117 years old no he's yeah he died
weekend at Burning is his ass out there
just coming in and voting he's a
hologram you got Dianne Feinstein 98
years old well yeah I mean maybe that's
generous she might be 198. yeah she's
scared you got McConnell you got Pelosi
you got Schumer they're 80 plus years
old running the country if Mitch
McConnell's not an alien then I don't
yeah I don't know his age is the problem
or just being in that Jersey Shore House
too long you're still done you should be
out by 40. I don't care if you you know
if you're 89 you got an 84. that's fine
Jersey Shore
house oh my God you got this Nookie out
there yeah whatever you guys want to do
you want to play Bingo you know like I
don't know what they're doing you know
but anyway so I don't know Elizabeth I
gotta give you a little pushback right
here okay bring it my grandma's 92 years
old okay yeah I love my grandma to death
yeah okay I don't want her running the
country at this point Pat's dad is one
of the wisest men I know
how old is Papa now turned 81 last week
okay and I mean this sincerest way I
don't want him running the country I
want his son running the country young
healthy vibrant dedicated I want no I
agree Gabriel being the concern
saying the age is not the issue it's how
long they've been there yeah so you
don't think it's both so you're saying I
think it's the 80s and 90s and 100 year
olds that are running the country you
want Hunter Biden to run the country
and the White House got it okay no I
don't know what he's saying is he wants
the Santas Adam wants DeSantis or Newsom
even after the UFC fight you said
took here that was really cool when he
walked out he was so sad I'm not gonna
lie that was kind of dope yeah it was it
was a moment you felt him I didn't see
him coming you felt by the way
surprising events something very
surprising happened which I'm sure a lot
of people are going to be shocked with
Mike Pence was boot at the NRA what yeah
he was did you hear about it yeah
it was in his home state and again and
Trump got a two-minute uh Standing
Ovation at the event uh in his speech
first speech since being indicted on
felony charges New York Trump promised
to remain a loyal friend and fearless uh
champion of the country's largest gun
rights lobbying group as he seeks to be
a party's nominee for 2024 presidential
election he appeared to acknowledge the
crowd's frosty response to Pence his
former running mate the NRA event was
attended by several Republican hopefuls
including Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and former United Nations Ambassador
Nikki Haley highlighting how the NRA's
endorsement remains powerful and highly
coveted amongst Republicans how
important is the NRA endorsement by the
way that's big it's it's it's very
important I think that's why ironically
your boy desans has put out his
anti-trump your boy your boy is
anti-trump AD I want to say the same day
saying Trump was bad on the Second
Amendment because I mean NRA guns like
that's it's a lot bigger than people
realize yeah
it's pretty wild you know you know how
you think about NRA right now if if
somebody is member of NRA it's kind of
like oh my god did you know yeah he's
part of the NRA how could you be part of
the NRA and uh John F Kennedy was a
proud card carrying member of the NRA it
was a very normal thing back in the days
both the Dems and the Republicans wanted
the endorsement now it's just on the
right uh when it comes down to this but
what if you were to say Mike Pence where
will he peek okay one let's say he runs
okay how like what percent do you think
is going to be his Peak like you know
remember Herman Cain went all the way up
I think he had 18 at one point Newton
went to 23 or Sanders got to 20 21 you
know or so Ross Pro got to 19 or 20 what
do you think Pence is going to go to so
I'll give you I'll give you two answers
here
um number one I think you know High
single digits maybe it's you know seven
eight nine percent at best right right
now it's two percent but but we all know
let me tell you who I think Mike Pence
is going to be
you know uh when it's uh you know it's
NBA season right now and you know like
let's say uh you know the Dallas
Mavericks need to win their final game
in order to make the playoffs and
they're playing against the Houston
Rockets and Houston's been long out of
the playoffs they got no chance but they
want to beat the [__] out of Dallas Yeah
okay or it's like the Miami Dolphins
they're not making the playoffs if
they're playing the Patriots and all
they want to do is be a spoiler and they
don't care their season's done they know
that they're not winning but they have
their sights on winning that last game
of the season why to ruin the Patriots
season to ruin Dallas Maverick season we
just saw Dallas get eliminated from the
playoffs I don't think we understand the
Vendetta that Mike Pence has against
Donald Trump I don't think we're going
to fully realize that until it gets so
ugly on that debate stage with Trump
with DeSantis with Pence possibly with
Chris Christie we know Nikki Haley will
be there Tim Scott
we're gonna see Mike Pence on stage
saying I was his vice president he
endangered my life and my family he is
unfit to be president
if you don't think that's gonna
he's gonna do it of course he is and I
still think that Trump will get the
nomination of course but it's gonna but
what may happen this is just my opinion
tear it down all you want is that it's
going to get so ugly and ugly and ugly
that there's going to be a wounded
candidate coming into the general
election and sleepy ass Joe Biden is
just gonna Sleepwalk potentially into
the presidency because it's gonna be so
much fighting on the Republican side of
things that's my opinion but when you
see people like the pencils like you
know you have Z the hell with that two
percent you have zero chance of touching
Trump let alone the sentence so I think
all those people on that stage are
either put there strategically just like
you said to make them look like [__] so
that the left even is going to learn
more stuff about them to give them
talking points to talk [__] you know
you're losing that race but Trump is
Trump is number one right now
nobody's touching like so those people
is it just for their resume Pat like I
ran for president in 2024. you're it's a
it's a lost battle before you even go in
like what are you what are you doing you
know you know what I mean why are you
announcing for what listen if you've
gone in that world yeah of the world of
politics and you're gonna plan on
writing a book or Legacy Kids you have
to have your Wikipedia say former 2024
presidential candidate okay got you like
if if if I was any one of you that are
born here yeah at one point you have to
figure out a way to run for president
and to say Vincent oshana 2032
presidential candidate former
presidential uh you know candidate can I
get in for 2000 can we do it for this
one I don't know if we can do it
I think I think that's a part of it the
other part of it as well is
a lot of these guys run because they get
a job afterwards so there's a job that
you're fighting for uh remember when
Trump won the day he won you know
they're like well typically when a
United candidate wins you know they take
a week off or a month off or they don't
do anything the guy was in the office
the next day I love it and he was
interviewing Romney that walked into his
office I don't know if you remember what
Romney walked into this office you're
like yeah what the hell is Romney doing
and everybody's just meeting meaning
meeting because this is like hey do you
want a job let's talk about it do you
want this shot let's talk about I'll
give you this job well if I give you
this job are you gonna so that's kind of
like the next part so meanwhile Joe's
sleeping 90 of people are running for a
job they're not running to be president
what job would Mike Pence be running for
at this point though he's already been
vice president he's already been
Governor it's easy to take shots at Mike
Pence but same people that like Trump
forget that he played a very important
role uh at that time because he brought
in the side of where he was the Indiana
I want to say you know conservative safe
and some people that were like man I'm a
little worried about him he brought more
safety in like you know when I started
an insurance company I had a reputation
of being very competitive you know loud
you know doing my thing and I upset a
lot of different people I brought
certain people in that got those that
were worried about coming over to us to
say okay that guy's there they're gonna
be fine that guy's there I feel safer so
it's a strategic hire that you have so
you can take shots at him all you want
the guy was a hero for a lot of trump
fans back in 2015-20s yeah and I think
he played his partner it's like a player
you got that you forget Ray Allen hit
the shot he got a championship game yes
just give him the credit I hate Ray
Allen as much as you want today I get it
but the guy still hit the shot got you
chips you could make the case that he
got Trump elected because he won over
the Christian event he was very
important I think it was very important
what I don't like now is that sometimes
this is what happens is okay who's more
important Pence or Trump to get in to
the White House who's more important
who's the bigger driver to get into
today not even a conversation you need a
percentage of them when they won in 2016
what percentage 2016. what percentage of
the credit of trump winning was Trump
what percentage of the credit of uh
Trump going to the White House was Pence
25 no way guys what are you talking
about 90 10. it's it's 99 to 1. really
yeah because you you didn't win the what
do you call it the the primary by you
know you want it because it's like this
is the guy right and then you announce
who it is so it's 99 him it's one him
here's a problem
you know if you wrote on someone's
coattail and you go up and you flip it's
it's a it's a little bit that's what his
DNA is today that's his reputation today
uh you know and by the way Democrats
love them CNN loves them MSNBC loves
them he's a great tool by the way expect
him to be on TV 60 Minutes CBS ABC all
of this stuff for for 16 straight months
every day and then he's gonna get a 10
million dollar book deal 5 million
dollar book deal and then he's going to
be the guy that's gonna have a
consultant you know half a million
dollar your job with CNN MSNBC to do
talking yeah that's what he's going to
be doing yeah so but it is what it is he
played it's like it's like a Scottie
Pippen I was watching a video today
about how Scottie Pippen was um
the guy and then after the Last Dance
there was a big follow now between the
two of them yeah because Scotty then
came out and he wrote a book and he said
what he says what do you want to be
remembered as I want to be remembered as
the greatest of all time dude come on
bro that's what he wants to Scotty said
I want to be remembered have you seen
this interview whatever it is it's just
I want to be remembered as a solution
when Robin suddenly thinks
he's Batman yes
if you
you're going to be a better Robin being
the best Robin you can be correct versus
you all of a sudden thinking you know
anyways this just took me to complete
let me ask you a question yeah well it's
delusional you actually think you said
that CNN you know these msnbcs they love
Pence now you actually think they love
him I think they look at him as a useful
idiot well but that's do you still love
a useful idiot of course they're like oh
uh Trump's boot licking VP is now
anti-trump it's Saturday night 11
o'clock yeah three people aren't texting
you back one of the girls does
you love her
you'll love him I'm just trying to give
you an analogy that you relate to yeah
Adam just went to this last Saturday you
know what Mary a quick shout out to you
you're amazing yeah you are anyways all
right so okay next story let's go into a
little bit of Chicago okay with what
happened with Chicago Rob if you want to
find that clip there uh and then also
I'm gonna I'll find the Tay tweet
because I love what Tate said and then
how he responded back to it so Chicago
mayor elect condemns teen takeover chaos
but says it's not constructive to
demonize the youth hundreds of young
people descended on downtown Chicago for
two nights of chaos with two teenage
boys being shot during the Mayhem
Chicago mayor-elect Brandon Johnson
condemned the behavior but warned
against demonizing youth who have been
starved of opportunities in their
communities nine adults and six
juveniles were arrested in connection
with the Takeover with most of the
arrests bring being for reckless conduct
Johnson called for the creation of safe
spaces for you to gather under adult
guidance and supervision John since past
support for reallocating funds from the
police department to other social
services come under attack during the
Mayoral race but he has since distanced
himself from that position saying he
will not reduce the police budget while
arguing that hiring more officers will
not solve the city's crime problems okay
do you have the clip to show what
happened in Chicago Rob if you got it if
if you don't what do you what are your
thoughts on what's going on in Chicago
right now I mean it doesn't look good I
don't know if it's a wake-up call to a
lot of people but how many more of these
things needs to happen you know for them
to have a wake-up call you know the the
people who are paying the price for this
are the same ones that voted for this
guy right and elected him I mean it's
possible that's what they deserve or
maybe that's what they want and those
that don't want that either moved or
vote differently but if you stay there
you have to be okay I mean no one
wanting to raise a happy family wants
the state I mean they can't remain there
if that's their priority so clearly they
have other priorities you know
have you seen any of these clips on
what's going on crazy I've seen a few
but
yeah it's pretty wild there's literally
it's lawlessness in Chicago bro when
cops don't want to show yo you know Pat
cops won't go to certain neighborhoods
because of the gang situation like
they're just like listen you're on your
own just take shelter and just get the
hell out of there basically she's
nailing like how do you keep voting
because money they just got rid of
Lightfoot the new guy he's this is
there's a horse yeah he's worse but they
keep voting him in and I feel I mean
obviously some people can't leave but if
you if you vote these people in and this
is what you get
say it's on you yeah you know what I
mean so
explain to me the context here because
I've seen some ridiculous Clips here
this is what this was an organized teen
takeover was this
just a bunch of teenagers saying you
know what we're gonna we're gonna
organize and just go Raise Hell burn
[__] down and just pray about Buddy
nobody was shot no innocent person was
shot or nothing it was just like hey
let's just go down there and call us and
wouldn't feel this are they not what are
their demands are they angry about
something what did something happen well
no there was no killing there was no
nothing it was just you know what F the
city and let's let's just can you raise
Rob can you pull up that video of the
mob beating up the woman trying to enter
her house yeah and I'm talking about
look how many people are beating this
girl not this one no not this one you
did it right before yeah that's it
that's it right there look there's this
lady it seems like she's just trying to
get into her hand look at that be in the
living 30 people just start beating the
[__] out of her that's attempting you're
stomping her in the head that's attempt
okay for what reason for nothing nothing
could you imagine if that were 30 white
people beating up a black guy oh forget
it what did you imagine what would be
happening if that was 30 white guys
beating up a tree in the middle she's
like I didn't do anything boom and she's
just getting stomped out this to me is
disgusting if you don't call all out
[__] like this whether you're black
you're white you're Asian you're Latino
you're part of the problem I was
disgusting that's the moment Chicago so
there's no guns I wish she had a gun
because I would have shot everybody's
ass that's trying to stomp me on my
[__] head that's ridiculous bro yeah
we're doing and guess what she should be
moving out of the city her next thing
after trying to arrest people and bring
them to court move the hell out of
Chicago if she's even functional right
now you know that she's gonna be
interviewed across the board you know
Fox is going to bring her on and if I'm
CNN
MSNBC yeah I bring her on also
unbelievable bro unbelievable you bring
Quran also yeah you think you think
they're going to bring her on well they
should there's a difference between
there's a lot of things they should do
they would never talk about the story
that's [__] this is against their
narrative but that is [__] takes it
imagine living in Chicago on purpose by
choice seriously imagine being a
full-grown adult and waking up in
Chicago looking at the entire globe and
then looking around you at the [__]
you reside and then saying yes I want to
live here then somebody response back
and he says this after tweeting this
thousands of people from Chicago replied
something along the lines of shut up you
wouldn't last a day here would I get in
Shadow Rob as some sort of Defense kind
of proves my point completely doesn't
right so we agree Chicago is a
crime-written dump I mean listen that
that's exactly the point one of one of
the things that happens is
I had a sales leader I talked to one
time and I S and I would have we're
having a back and forth and I said you
realize who likes you
she says what do you mean I said think
about which one of your sales people
like you she says who I said you're
losing your best salespeople
and you're keeping the worst ones
you prefer people listening to you
and you know wanting to just like you
and kiss your ass 24 7 over killers that
want to compete Dominate and get to work
you want people to just conform to you
and fear you rather than people that
want to go compete you can always tell a
person's identity by who they keep and
who they lose we got a lot of vice
presidents in our insurance company I
watch some of our guys and they keep
Killers they're a killer I want some of
our guys they lose their killers and
they keep their complainers their
complainer that's just what it is so a
city
who does things like this guess what
you're going to lose the person that
just wants to go to work and create a
business and you know send their kids to
a good school and just do their part
they're not allowed they just kind of
want to do their part those are very
much of positive citizens that you want
to keep you lose the you lose those
people you don't have a city they're
going to go to a different place so you
know somebody said the other day there's
an article from Insider bash in Florida
and it says something like a remote work
is killing Florida as a retirement
Paradise look at the title remote work
yeah it's killing Florida as a
retirement Paradise did you understand
the title are you getting what they're
trying to say okay so let me read it to
you for some of us people that are not
Columbia grad uh you know Brilliant
Minds that uh uh let me go to this page
now so check this out
Florida's Rising home prices are
threatening the state's reputation as a
retirement Haven median home values on
Florida are 33 compared to last year
compared to an 18 Nationwide increase to
eight of ten most overvalued home
markets in the US are in Florida the
state has long promoted itself as an
affordable retirement Paradise but
increasing competition from private
investors combined with the rise of
remote work has contributed to the work
uh to afford housing and housing prices
threatened to end the middle class
stream of spending final days in Florida
unless Florida builds more housing and
raises wages the trend of rising home
prices May delay young people's
retirement plans and threaten the
state's economy
who's gonna fall for the [__] the same
person now can you can you let's find
out who the writer is go find who wrote
this article and let me guess Gabby you
went to Columbia click on her profile
that's so funny oh no just click on her
name it's gonna take you there and tell
us who she is writer Brooklyn she worked
at The Verge the drift above the Nations
other people she's co-founder veterans
what school did you go to Gabby can we
go find a gabby Del Vie there's not a
lot of them out there what school did
she'll buy it zoom in there's a this is
a difference
immigration report advice news makes
sense prior to advise she was a reporter
at Vox and writer at Online daily beasts
all of those things tells you who she is
yeah all of those things tell you who
she is
NYU okay same thing makes sense didn't
you just talk about NYU earlier yeah
exactly so there you go you want to say
something like this
good for you this whole remote works you
know bashing forward as a place to be
listen guys the workers the independent
thinkers the people that want to be left
alone the bad asses you want in your
community are moving to places like
Tennessee Texas Florida Idaho I can give
you five other states and they're
leaving places like Chicago Illinois New
York California I can give you five
other states they're living it's just
what's happening anyways what are your
thoughts on this story here yeah no I
agree with everything you said I don't
understand who would stay there unless
it's someone who has to and has no way
out
a lot of people are probably in that
state but it could go back to what you
said about like American values changing
if your values are I want to raise a
family and put food on the table and
make sure my kids grow up to be normal
citizens of the world you would not
remain in Chicago so either people's
values are changing
um and we're not understanding what
people are starting to align with or
people simply can't get out but there's
no one would willingly want to stay
there and have a normal responsible
happy family life you know right now
we're looking at buying 10 to 20 acres
to build our campus
and we're talking to Fort Lauderdale
we're looking at Pompano we're even
considering Miami that's what we're
looking at right now we're going to
build our campus we're going to do
movies we're going to docs we're going
to do shows we're going to have our on
top of Johnny Carson's that are going to
come here we're going to bring the
coolest cats that are willing to have
conversations from both sides that are
likable they're smart that are
intellectual and they also don't think
they know it all and they're still
trying to learn and we're going to
compete and I cannot tell you how many
people around the country message me and
say Pat are you recruiting we like you
guys and what you're doing how you guys
are we want to be part of it people are
sick of states that are hurting
individuals that just want to be left
alone California just came up with this
one policy here goes full communism
utilities to base what they charge on
how much you make so utilities if you
want to pay electricity in California
now they're going to use a progressive
system the more money you make your your
bill is going to be more makes you want
to move back
California so so three utility companies
in California have filed a joint
proposal to charge customers a flat rate
based on their income with reduced usage
charges based on consumption this
proposal part of a compliance with 2021
California state government legislation
requiring such plans for utilities the
fixed income rate for households would
be as low as 15 bucks a month for
low-income households and up to 85 bucks
more per month for households earning
more than 180 000 a year critics argued
that this initiative is an attempt to
Implement Marxism and communism where
capitalism is inescapable and the only
way to Prosperity they suggest that such
policies would incentivize low-income
households and penalize those earning
more than 180k per year which would lead
to a decline in productivity and the
standard of living that's common sense
yes okay the way he described nothing
about what he said was out of the
ordinary why would somebody stay in
California today
why would somebody think the weather and
the traffic Pat they just love it I'm
going to lay this thing are you going
this way I'm going to lay you uh Friday
and Saturday we're going to be in L.A
I'm speaking I I think I'm in Corona on
Saturday when you go back how do you
like be honest what do you I mean you
miss it because you're from love it you
know what I love that you get to leave I
can close my eyes and drive the freeways
I know every street I probably drove a
few hundred thousand miles in California
selling policies yeah you know and
building my business I love it there
there's the the people the the
relationships all I'm a Glendale High
School kid you know you go by the high
school and you're looking at the Nitros
and you know very proud of you know
being out of a thousand students class
880 out of my thousand graduating class
very proud proud of the GP and all that
stuff that we had
um no you know there's a certain element
to it going through all the roads the
streets we did that once together right
I'm driving and I'm saying hey here's
where I want this we've done it a few
times yeah and it's great the fastest
I've ever driven in my life
165. living by the way to drive 165 on
four four or five foot which allegedly
he's claimed yeah I would never I was
just gonna say don't say people have
like somebody heard that you were doing
keep in mind it was during covid so
there was no that's going on so it's a
great state but I'm telling you more and
more people stop me and say I left my
state and moved to Florida after
watching the video of how great Florida
is I left my state and even though you
talk about Florida I chose to move to
Tennessee I moved to Texas I moved to
Idaho it's happening and it's going to
become more and more and more so the
part about the six weeks that we talked
about with DeSantis
let's flip it yeah does this cause some
people to want to leave Florida
well that gets some people to say I'm
sorry man I can't live here okay because
these policies are also moving me away
from the state you know I can't do
something like this because I do believe
good and bad policies are going to force
certain people out and attract certain
people in maybe that is strategic what
he's doing what do you think I mean if
nothing else is going to make it a very
rare State I mean I was told in 2016 but
even through 2020 that this was still a
swing state once this passes those who
remain I mean that's it it's a red state
so I think unfortunately we're changing
the map quite a bit and now we're
learning where you want to live if
you're Republican or where you want to
live if you're a Democrat and there's
not a lot of places to go if you just
want to be around people who might
disagree with you but you know that you
might enjoy having dinner with so that's
the unfortunate part that we're really
making States choose what they want to
be and making people decide whether well
I mean nobody's more purple here than
you though that's fair that's why I go
between New York and here I cannot
settle in one spot so do you go to New
York oh my God all these red people and
you go to Florida you know you go to New
York you're like oh my God all these
blue people yeah I miss the running go
to the right like oh this you guys are
so annoying to go back is that kind of
how you are listening on the plane
[Laughter]
oh man that's crazy okay next story
let's see what we got next to go through
do we want to talk a little bit about
wheat let's talk a little bit about
wheat so there's a community did you
guys talk about the league Pentagon
stuff Pat did you guys let's be blunt
please okay legal weed is turning New
York workers into zombies great so this
is a New York Post story let's see what
they have to say
so uh apparently uh let me see this
thing okay the decriminalization of
marijuana has led to widespread use
amongst service employees in New York
City resulting in lethargy disengagement
and forgetfulness hey can you remember
to put that on my schedule I got you
yeah yeah we're never in the calendar
minimum wage should be lowered since
many workers have become hopelessly
stunned at or dumb who said that by the
way let me know something about the
minimum kid now that's just a quote so
there are several examples of service
employees who were stoned up the Wazoo
and unable to perform their jobs
including a cashier who forgot to give
change of service that's worker that's a
lost a car and a restaurant server who
lost the credit card that uh acreage
odor of marijuana uh smoke is everywhere
even in Broadway theaters and subway
cars Progressive politicians are
responsible for throwing the city into
trash by decriminalizing marijuana and
allowing the widespread use of the drug
amongst service employees do you see
that in New York when you go there or
not really I smell it you smell it yeah
so you're happier in New York I have
actually never smoked weed in my life
I've never tried it swear to God I don't
know anything about this except my high
school friends who would act very
similarly to what they're describing
here you can't say that you have to
admit to everybody here on here on live
podcast promise you didn't inhale if you
live in New York you can uh lie detect
is that a thing you can lie yeah I
promise never in my life no no what I'm
saying is my point is more if you you
know if you're in New York if you're
around friends that are smoking weed
you're getting high I knew what they
were doing I wasn't around them oh okay
when I was 16 I was sitting at home with
a cast on my leg just trying to figure
out how to walk it's funny when I'm
around the kids and the kids are like
Dad what smell is that so that's skunk
yeah it is it is
what that is Adam what are your thoughts
about this you may be looking at the
story and you may say you would support
something like this if DeSantis did this
in Florida is that kind of what you're
thinking yeah well let me tell you this
story is such [__] okay this is such
[__] why because the let me tell you
something about These Guys these cash
registers These Guys these Uber drivers
you think they're waiting for [__]
weed regulation to start smoking weed
yeah these guys have been hitting the
bong for decades yeah okay they're not
waiting for weed regulation to set and
be like finally I can smoke my weight
it's just True You're Nobody they're
saying smoking it no no regardless
listen nobody can say they can't smoke
that weed no one's saying that that they
can't do it behind closed doors right
this is illegally oh they're gonna do it
no no regardless well let me ask you a
question if I'm building a company and
you got guys that are okay I'm gonna
take a smoke break they're outside and
I'll turn them you know they come back
in hey so Johnny how you doing good man
how you doing like I'm good so you're
gonna you're gonna finish that video
yeah boss I got it okay
dude like five o'clock you forgot he
leaves and so productivity doesn't go up
there is no I'm not saying that there's
benefits from doing it but the
difference is these guys are now smoking
legally there's a difference between
they've been smoking for a while you're
right but now you're getting into an
Uber and you're like this guy just
smoked a joint before me getting in here
yeah yeah here we go we'll open a
Windows no it's cold it's New York I
fully agree with you fully agree with
you but what I'm saying is yeah they're
gonna do it regardless whether it's
legal whether it's illegal where they
can buy it on the street where they can
buy it from their drug dealer they're
gonna get dirt if they want to get high
they're going to get high they're not
waiting for government regulation to set
it and be like finally I can take myself
can I tell everybody what you're doing I
know you're you know how sometimes
you're talking to me but the audience
doesn't know the conversation we just
had right before the podcast yeah go
ahead okay so here's what Adam is
requesting and I haven't yet approved it
Rob you know about this this was a
length you're gonna reveal our private
conversation are you okay with it if I
tell them that you know what I'm a
teacher wants us to do podcasts smoking
weed
not doing it he wants to do a live
podcast smoking I told you medium choice
between gummies cookies and the actual
tape like I'm smoking of the weed and
we're not doing it now if Adam wants to
do that it's a different story the
audience would like to see that I think
Oliver Stone wanted to do that we even
brought him what do you call the humidor
we bought for him I'm curious so what
the chat if you had to guess the
percentage of what the chat would say
yes to Pat and everybody's smoking weed
or you don't want me smoking what do you
think it would be what I I think it
would be 80 or high I want to see
pattern I think 80 I'm gonna go ahead
and say this Elizabeth the audience is
gonna say
85. I'm telling you it won't be 80
points come on guys and girls let me
tell you one quick I have a feeling it's
gonna be 65 percent
would you like to see pbd pbd smoke weed
what I'm telling it's gonna be 65 and
Rogan if it's no no no no no no just
just us let's just see what they're
gonna say but go ahead yeah as much as
um it seems like I'm defending weed I I
I'm all I'm saying is These Guys these
guys are gonna be smoking it regardless
I will say that that you know you just
said regard you said regardless three
times okay what I thought about what
regard me you know what confused regard
me yeah have you seen Couples Retreat
seven years
regard me you don't know that guy the
reason why I know it's because I just
watch it with the kids this by the way
Couples Retreat what a movie that is
East Island you know what do they do
over there anyway
the ass
they're making it so strong these days
and and I I totally can empathize with
what they're saying here lethargy
disengagement forgetfulness lethargy
wait one of me yeah
Adam has lethargy today and you make fun
of this ESL speaking guy and you have
like a 4.0 GP and ice
like someone is lethargic Okay I'm
thinking of uh you can never talk about
that again
Adam's newest product is uh made out of
leather yeah if you're a leopard with
lethargy well I forgot my story I forgot
my thought over here oh here's the story
so I remember being in college smoking
weed for like first time yeah and super
stoned and uh now it's even stronger the
weed these days and I remember being
like all right I gotta go to the store
and I gotta buy some stuff
so I remember I got in the car I opened
the car door sat in the seat put my key
in the ignition and I was sitting in
shotgun
laughs that's what you know I was just I
was like oh [__] I'm about to get out of
the car
walk around go into the driver's seat
the whole time I'm thinking if anyone
just saw me
could I just could I went through this
fast idiot I'm in the United States Air
Force six years only smoke a couple
times before because I have really
strict parents I get out first day I do
the Volcano Vaporizer for the people out
there that smoke you know what that is
Pat it's this big silver thing yeah it
feels it heats the weed like the Vapes
now it fills up a garbage bag I go I hit
the whole thing and I'm like let me
drive to Long Beach I'm gonna go to the
beach I'm gonna go have this thing right
here look at that bag it fills up so Pat
I hit it on the 405. I'm gone I'm only
20 miles an hour a cop pulls up in front
of me which is always you know I'm like
he's supposed to be back there the cop
turns on his lights and he starts doing
something called the traffic break which
you know what that is right Pat when the
cop turns on his lights and they start
swerving to slow down traffic I am so
high I just start following the cop I'm
like let me just start swerving now I'm
like are we in a commercial get arrested
no he pulled over
no no he's in front I'm following him do
this move oh he pulls over because
there's a bumper on the freeway he gets
out I get out and I follow him and I go
officer he's like I scared the [__] he's
like get the back in your car he's like
what's your problem like I'm sorry I
just and I got in the car
I was high as [__] never smoked after
that there you go finish no more weed to
bring this to to please you know so you
don't think we're all just part after
Jackie yeah lethargic I'd like to know
what the kind of tax revenue that the
the state of New York or even the state
of California has actually received from
legalizing this because there is money
in this right oh they're killing it for
taxing oh I mean listen to be honest the
leather industry
yeah and then the Middle East California
tax revenue a billion 300 million there
you go they're killing it bro yeah
there's a lot of money in weed 1.3
billion what about New York
oh my god dude Massachusetts you're less
how many lethargies come from all that
money it's permanent thing
okay all right so uh Adam you got that
out of your system what's the point
all right so 10 priciest cities in the
U.S where a three hundred thousand
dollar salary feels like a hundred
thousand dollars a year okay let's look
at this 10 prices and let's see how many
the cities of Florida are on this list
so if you want to go to it
priciest 10 cities number one is
New York City 312 000 a year is the
equivalent of a hundred thousand one
holy [__] so Hawaii is also 312. do you
have this or no if you can show the
stats Hawaii is 312. San Francisco is uh
uh 311 then it's Oakland why would you
what that's insane oh Oakland yeah 2 45.
Rob what are you doing to us here okay
there we go Oakland is right and get
lethargy Oakland 246 La 245 Long Beach
DC San Diego Boston Seattle interesting
okay go to the other side which is what
the 10 cheapest cities the 10 cheapest
cities is I okay there you go number one
Memphis Tennessee Wow El Paso to
Oklahoma City Corpus Christi Lubbock
Texas shout out to uh Daniel uh uh
Houston Texas Houston 125. that's pretty
wild to be look how many Texas is in
there Texas Texas Texas Texas Texas
Texas one two three if your leaders
bulletin guy seven out of ten is Texas
they're dominating okay that's pretty
wild so in other words if you want to
feel rich move to Texas right yeah
you're right if you want to do do not go
to California uh Texas is dominant by
the way there's no Florida nope Miami I
thought Miami would have been on the the
what do you call it expensive yeah
that's what I thought yeah but it's not
yeah because people don't make 100 Grand
in Miami so if we're going to go based
on this we're opening up a studio in
Memphis Tennessee okay we're gonna go to
Memphis and buy teammates so let's go
you're getting content from that place
by the way I'm surprised Houston's on
this list me too because Houston's got
20 30 million dollar homes you got oils
now the third largest city in America
just passed up Chicago oh really really
yeah
Houston's blowing Houston bigger than
Dallas
Houston is bigger than Dallas please
tell me your joking I mean when you
think of Texas you think of Dallas
Dallas Texas yeah nobody thinks of the
Houston type and top 10 largest cities
in America population
all right this is this is pretty
interesting population Oh you mean what
you thinking he's he's lethargy he's
there again this is what year
Houston just passed Up Chicago
the largest wow yeah go Dallas
population
go Dallas population Houston's two
million uh 300 000.
low-key it's just low I don't think
anybody would think that Houston is that
big I I'm not gonna when you think of
major cities you do not think of Houston
well Houston has double
damn
I didn't know that what
yep 2.288 you're telling me when you
think of major U.S cities Houston is on
your list I I wouldn't have thought that
maybe if you're a Hakeem Elijah one fan
but yeah no all right sorry wait you
wouldn't want to live in Houston that's
not what I said it's a little one no
well yeah yeah I don't want to live in
Houston I'm good in Miami I'm good Pat
what do you think the poll was for you
smoking weed I haven't I totally forgot
70. totally forgot about it yeah
it dropped I told you six people
you said 60. I said 65. you know your
audience wait till the end of the
podcast and see how it looks out but
that means yes yeah I can't believe some
late morning yes 35 no I still have a
6139 no I know you said that you're
gonna do whatever the audience decides
yeah or whatever you said you want to
smoke you can smoke it but what do you
mean you people
what do you mean you people for 400
years get cheese get cheese
steak is hilarious
man so where are you at with these
cities by the way when you see stuff
like this the cities no if I'm right now
if I am somebody that is not in the best
of place financially and I'm thinking
about having a family and raising a
family if if if I'm doing okay
financially I'm moving to Florida
okay I'm moving to Tennessee you know if
I'm not doing well financially and I
can't afford private school and I'm
thinking next 10 20 years where I'd like
to go pick a city in Texas it's a great
place to go to uh Dallas is a great
place Plano if you can live in Plano
phenomenal City Dallas got a lot of
great places to be living in Houston's
got a lot of great places to be living
in we got a couple of our guys that
moved to Houston uh uh Austin is very
different Austin is not Texas a lot of
people think Austin is Texas until they
go to us and then they realize Austin is
more San Francisco really Austin like a
lot of San Francisco's not Texas well
Austin is weird some may say that they
want to keep it unpacked like because
I've been I've been to all these cities
to do comedy shows but what's the
difference between Austin compared to
like uh Dallas or like a Houston it's
more hipster oh oh god really you don't
know how how I've never been to Austin
I've been in one place so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna go to we'll
go to Joe's new club okay go visit him I
want to give him a gift okay we'll go to
his new club okay and we'll also go
around Austin please do what it's like
okay yeah awesome it's crazy I swear to
God I've never been awesome
what do you like is it like towards a
positive or towards a negative if you
say San Francisco I don't want to even
be there what do I like about Austin
yeah
um I mean would I live there is if if
what you're asking well you're saying
how do you compare it to San Francisco
it is Texas's version of San Francisco
it's the best way to put it liberal like
you know you know it's it's by the way
Austin is also the Silicon Valley of of
Texas as well so it's so silicon silicon
yeah that's silicone leather Jeep so
like that's one of my words that they
correct me up Silicone Valley so if it's
so liberal and so like that why would
somebody like Joe Rogan go there which
is I think that's wrong because it's not
California well obviously nothing I mean
but because it's California without the
policies got it okay yeah it's
California without the policy got you
okay by the way he moved to the right
place for him yeah okay and his Comedy
Club the mother I said I said Joe how's
the comedy club eight months
sold out I mean you can't get tickets
it's crazy because he'll add a show and
then it'll be sold second without yes
seconds yeah this is you're talking
about you know what he's done to Comedy
this is like you know like where's the
place basketball players wanted to go
play in New York Rucker Parker park
right like this is the Rucker Park of
Comedy wow it's crazy last night they
posted a photo of a drop-in comedian
guess who the drop-in comedian was Bill
Burr Bill Burr just drops in and does a
spot oh my God by the way that's kind of
like in New York saying guys there's
gonna be a player showing up tomorrow
Kevin Durant shows up come and play with
Kevin Durant that's what happens at the
Comedy Cellar in New York you know that
Pat I want to go to Austin please I'm in
by the way you got to play a game when
you're in Austin okay it's called
homeless or hipster oh God you just
gotta guess guess who's who is that guy
homers or hipster I was uh three for ten
I just couldn't figure out I'm like that
guy is definitely homeless like I own a
tech company but wait when you play this
game were you smoking and were you
laughing no whatever what word is that
no okay let's let's try to hit two more
stories but by the way what what would
be good is these stories this why people
are fleeing blue cities for red States
this is kind of basically proving your
point you want to go to that well it's
just essentially it's doubling down by
the way it's New York Times which you
know this is once where New York Times
is um and the Daily Mail all right let's
go to New York time and let's see what
they got to say here we go why people
are fleeing blue cities for red States
okay uh fastest growing states in the
U.S between 2010 and 2020 were mostly
red States like Texas Georgia Florida
Tennessee South Carolina the trend
accelerated during the pandemic and most
of the population gaining states are
governed by Republicans these states are
more pro-business and have lower taxes
and fewer restrictions on home
construction resulting in lower housing
prices and more job opportunities the
growth in these states is mostly in
their Metro areas which are often blue
cities in uh red States Republican
policies provide the general business
climate but Democrats at the local level
influence the school social services and
Civic atmosphere that attract highly
educated
workers a red blue uh uh mashup seems to
work with the conservative States
authorities at odds with the more
liberal cities authorities over things
like minimum wage laws and lgbtq rights
okay so they're kind of trying to
suggest and say hey guys like we
understand you you guys are kicking our
asses but what would be better is if you
guys are willing to work with us a
little bit that's kind of how I read
this article but it's known is anyone
surprised who's moving to Red States is
this like a story where you're sitting
there being flabbergasted saying oh wow
shocking no people like lower taxes
people like low regulation people like
it when the government States out of the
you know stays out of the business of
how you want to parent and raise your
kids these are all like you went back to
you said something you said I want to go
back to what you said the America uh uh
not America First policy you were
talking about what America was founded
on the policies that were you know yeah
the values that my parents escaped the
Soviet Union to you know to be a part of
to raise me and that I wish to God will
exist when I have kids one day you know
yeah
uh uh yeah I mean hurry up because it's
like oh my God what these guys are up to
now these crazy things are happening
okay so are you good with that story did
you have a comment or did you just want
to well there's a I love the quote by
Nasim Nicholas Talib you know naseeb
Talib he says I am
uh at the federal level level
libertarian right at the state level
Republican essentially this right at the
local level Democrat caring about your
community I guess and at friends and
family level a socialist so there's
there there's minutia in all this if
saying that doesn't convince you of the
the fattestness of the left and the
right labels nothing will so that
it kind of just Different Strokes for
different folks but to prove to that
point uh get out of my way let me just
do my thing as a Libertarian for the
federal government for the state
government obviously if they're
pro-business people are moving to these
states but in your family you know maybe
you can be a little bit more
left-leaning and give stuff away yeah
very close family yeah did you you
signaling that was a second family it's
a family yeah I think he makes sense
this is the first time we've had two
Jews and two Assyrians on our party yes
I feel like Miss books out here I feel
like family we're having a great time I
love it yeah and a proud boy yeah
that was perfect that's amazing I mean
yeah I'm just so thankful you got out of
you January take the story you want to
talk about Walmart shutting down four
stores in Chicago do you want to talk
about India population surpassing China
do you want to talk about new
Massachusetts bill would give companies
uh with a four-day work week's tax
incentives or do you want to talk about
ai's threat to humanity will be far
greater if China Masters it first which
one do you do let's do it okay so let's
do that one so ai's threat to humanity
will be far greater if China Masters it
first Gordon Chen who knows something
about China he lived there as a lawyer
for I think 19 or 20 years okay so
according to China expert Gordon Chang
AI poses a direct threat to humanity but
it'll be more of a threat to humanity of
China Masters it before we do China's
proposed measures to ensure AI
development adheres to socialist values
and does not disrupt the economic or
social order may also hinder its AI
development furthermore China's
political politically repressive system
that relies on censorship is not
conducive to AI development and AI may
not react well to such restrictions
Chinese Tech firms like Alibaba and
Baidu have have created Bots to rival
banned AI products like open eye
openai's Chad gbt finally China is a
great AI capabilities and access to vast
amounts of data give it a built-in
advantage to AI development creating an
arms race and lowering Global standards
thoughts
yeah um what was the quote that it's
it's dangerous of China Masters before
we do I think that stands for anything
that's not just AI anything that China
Masters before America does is probably
going to kill us
um I have been convinced for years that
technology will take my life so this is
further proof I am terrified of all this
stuff I don't understand it I don't know
why people trust it
um so blindly and I don't know why we're
okay having it when we know that
countries like China Russia Iran
everyone else has it as well possibly at
a higher level is that why you use an
extel you're still using old school
phone she's still got the flip folks I
love it see the phone I wish yeah but
isn't it scary Pat when you have people
like you know Elon Musk saying like
listen yeah I'm involved with it and I'm
gonna be making a shitload of money off
of it but it's going to be dangerous and
they're giving you the warning sign
right now that it's going to be taking
over there's already I'm seeing robots
working what by the way did you see that
one robot pet that was working at some
warehouse and it just fell over from
being overworked did you see that um
yeah this is this is the clip where he's
saying like well this is uh Elon was on
Tucker last night and they talked about
AI regulation and uh Elon brings up a
great point about regulation if you want
me to play yeah yeah go for it Rob your
audio is very low so race
after something terrible has happened it
may be too late to actually put the
regulations in place the AI may be in
control at that point you think
that's real it is it is conceivable that
AI could take control and reach a point
where you couldn't turn it off and it
would be making
the decisions for people yeah absolutely
absolutely no it's that that's
definitely where things are headed
uh for sure okay
I mean um
things like like say uh chat EBT which
is uh based on jpd4 from open AI which
is a company that I uh
played a a critical role in in creating
unfortunately back when it was a
non-profit
yes
um
I mean the the reason uh opening eye
exists at all is that
um Larry Page and I used to be close
friends and I would stay at his house in
Palo Alto and I would talk to him later
tonight about uh AI safety and at least
my perception was that Larry was not
taking uh AI safety uh seriously enough
um and um what did he say about it he
really seemed to be
um
sort of a digital super intelligence
basically digital God if you will uh as
soon as possible um he wanted that yes
he's made many public statements over
the years uh that that the whole goal of
Google is uh what's called AGI
artificial general intelligence or
artificial super intelligence you know
and I agree with him that the there's
great potential for good
um but there's also a potential for bad
I said well what about you know we're
going to make sure humanity is okay here
um
and and and
uh and then he called me a speciesist
did he use that term yes
and there were Witnesses the other I was
the only one there when you called me a
specialist and so I was like okay that's
it uh I've yes I'm a speciesist okay you
got me
what are you
yeah I'm fully auspicious um
busted um
the new word that I just learned today
but by the way go ahead so you see this
how do you feel about what he's saying
here well the whole point is that he
brings up regulations but the only time
that we put regulations in place is
after something tragic happens are we
going to wait with AI until something
tragic happens before we start
regulating it and if that's the case it
may be too soon at that point the AI
could become self-aware self-conscious
and then how do you shut it so I got a
question for everybody here let's just
see what angle we take this okay so his
concern is he's trying to pump the
brakes on AI okay fine
so would you rather have it let's just
say you pump the brakes on AI on private
sector entrepreneurs you got to pump the
brakes on AI is the government also
going to pump the brakes never okay so
they're not going to pump the brakes
would you rather you have three options
private cannot go to AI it's overly
regulated but the US Government Can okay
uh or the both private and public can go
Ai and let it rip okay meaning like go
for it you can do as much as you want
government can do it and private can do
it which one of those two is just going
to be two which of those two would you
rather prefer
are you trusting more private with AI or
public with AI
I'll go to you first which one do you
prefer it's an interesting one yeah it's
hard because what he's saying is he's
pumped the brakes the government's not
going to pump the brakes so you're
telling privates pump the brakes on AI
so who's gonna pump the brakes do I want
them to monitor everything but you don't
want us to go and impose so who's going
to stop who's not no that's fair if
there's no way to get the government to
stop which there never is then we must
continue and hopefully have more
experience I agree then they do I agree
with her because I mean yeah you can't
this is such a slippery slope because
it's like everything that all those
movies all those iRobots and all the
warnings of what they're doing it's
coming out into our phase and we're
seeing I'm telling you right now Pat
it's happening like fast fast there's a
documentary called the transcendental
Man by uh something if you could look it
up uh he warned Pat of the art select
War not him other people in the
documentary artificial intelligence
against us
[Laughter]
I'm getting lethargic lethargic I'm
getting the Clem but that's the future
and it's scary and the guy was they're
warning it's coming and it's gonna it's
happening faster and faster and one of
his points was when we look at an aunt
Pat you don't think twice you just go
dead right that the robot is going to
get millions and millions and millions
of times smarter than us where that
robot's gonna turn on us and be like who
the who are you yeah telling you what to
do you know what I mean yeah
uh in the interview he says if every if
humans wanted to go around and kill
every chimp yeah we could kill every
chimp because we're strong we're not we
may not be stronger than gems but we're
smarter than chips we're the smartest
species on this Earth what happens when
there's something smarter than us then
we're smoking smoking like a true
species suspicious yeah you just care
about Humanity yeah so this guy's all
about the future in this documentary but
all the other people in the documentary
are like this guy is nuts you're asking
for the end of humanity because robots
are going to take over so well I think
well there every industry has regulation
we I mean SCC finra you know the EPA
there's there needs to be some sort of
Regulation here I mean even crypto needs
to be regulated right now but I mean I
think you bring up a good point about
government versus Private Industry so
what crypto needs to be regulated right
now I think there is I don't think I'm
not I'm not a fan of Central Bank
digital currencies but I think there
needs to be some sort of Regulation out
there I mean even even everything that
just happened with the Silicon Valley
Bank they lifted regulations disaster so
but they're also to your credit you know
the famous the the meme you ever seen
that Meme let me see where it's like
these two guys are talking and the guy
goes um did you hear about the new bill
or do you support the new bill and he's
like uh what new bill he's like it's the
bill that gives the government the No No
like I'm not in favor of it I don't know
if the government no so you know if you
can find that
were you going somewhere but there needs
to be a balance there needs to be a
public private partnership and an
agreement on what the hell is going on
with this AI I don't know about AI
enough to even to to weigh in on this
but I do trust Elon Musk on this well I
mean I don't trust anybody that created
it now is like that's like making a gun
and going like hey I don't trust it now
you made the gun you know I mean like
and the hell with the government or the
private the machine itself is going to
be superior than us that's the fear
that's the genuine fear is this machine
saying who are you to tell me what to do
and I have the power and the ammunition
to take over you that's the fear so I
don't care who has it once the machine
becomes too smart it's a wrap and you're
talking about the one made possibly here
imagine the one made by the Chinese oh
forget it forget it that's a different
level wow so I don't know have fun yeah
I I don't know I don't know if we can
fully put a pause to Innovation and I
don't know if I fully feel comfortable
saying you can innovate but I can't
right and hey I'm smarter and I'm going
to be more under control because I'm not
driven by power let me try to see what I
can do with this technology and I'll
tell you in a couple years how it's
going to help you yeah because I'm the
government and I'm here to help you you
know it's just a very honorable thing to
say we know when we look at the last
time the U.S population trusted the
government the most this guy named John
was president and his last name is
Kennedy yeah and it was 72 or 70 percent
today it's in the 20s people don't trust
the US government today it's just period
you know the weaponization the what
spying all this stuff just like look we
don't trust what you got going on right
now we kind of want to leave that part
Alone
um I I will say it's
when an Elon says it you got to give it
credibility he started you know it's
like when the vaccine guy who started
the vaccine he's sitting there now
saying look there's a lot of people that
invented the product and they turned
around they say I wasn't too happy about
what I produced not necessarily the
vaccine but certain things that they
invent maybe Elon is somebody we ought
to listen to but how we go about it is
the issue I'm not comfortable with it
being fully deregulated but again we're
going to see what's going to happen
apparently
um according to this uh former uh what
was it model that uh Harvard and
University of Pennsylvania
because of Technology
we have to stop it we have to figure out
a way to stop it and Elizabeth's got a
message to uh folks in DC and this guy
named Milan okay we should listen to
that so we're about to wrap up I do want
to admit to something it's going to be
very hard to do this
as a man who's uh very proud and there's
ego involved and you know all these
other things uh lethargic is the proper
way to not pronounce it but it is
lethargy it is so Adam was right over
here in front of him the whole time so
if you want to go what just happened
here if you want to go relax pump the
brakes I'm giving you this go on Google
go on Google type in the word uh uh uh
l-e-t-a-d pronounce and let Google tell
us this is a very uh interesting you
know maybe just go to chatpt
Let's Hear It Go ahead show it to us
lethargy exactly so very disappointed
it's lethargic but apparently it is
lethargy we have a big ESL community
that follows us we don't want we don't
want people going around lethargy yeah
it's lethargy don't give up on your
dreams you're gonna have haters out
there you're gonna have people they're
gonna get a [__] on you tell you that
you're an idiot that you're wrong I
promise you if you believe in that three
you double down for every one word you
mispronounce or you're accused of it I
get 10 coming this way okay well amid
all these accusations that I don't know
okay what was the name of the book
Elizabeth if you want to tell us about
your book and as well as some of the
projects you're working on so the
audience can follow you if you can maybe
tell us about this book finding my place
yeah
I was planning my place making my
parents American dream come true
right there but it's kind of a story
about me but mostly why I am who I am
which mostly can be summed up in because
my parents left the Soviet Union and
risked everything lost a lot so I could
be here so thank you for everyone's
support and you can follow me at
Elizabeth pipco anywhere you get social
media Elizabeth picks what's not a
common name is what you're saying it is
not no okay so put that Elizabeth pipco
Twitter Instagram put all the links
below it's great having you on we had a
lot of fun here today's podcast was a
little weird because we laughed a lot
and we learned English
gang we're doing this again on Thursday
I think Thursday will be home team with
Tom being on with us here we got a lot
of business topics to talk about this
Thursday have a good one we'll see you
guys on Thursday take care bye-bye